>>Chris DiBona: Hello, everyone.
My name is Chris DiBona. I am Google's open
source person. And they have me moderate this
each year, at least until they replace me
with someone better for next year.
I want to thank you all for coming.
One of the really nice things about the Fireside
Chats is you get really direct access to the
software engineers behind the software that
we all love, Android. And for the other Fireside
Chats, other technologies that we're not going
to talk about.
So that's actually a really special thing
in a lot of ways. And it's something that's
very appealing to me as an open source person,
because, you know, at its core, engineers
talking to engineers is what moves the entire
industry and computer science forward, and
that's something that I very much believe
in. So we are going to start today by doing
short introductions of our many, many panelists.
And we will take questions from the microphones
you see in the room here. We will pay no attention
to you at all unless you are in front of a
microphone, as well as from the moderator
instance that we set up.
So let's go ahead and start with Dave.
>>Dave Sparks: Hi, I am Dave Sparks. I am
the technical lead of the Android Media Framework,
that's media graphics, camera, video, stuff
like that.
>>Rebecca Zavin: Hi, I am Rebecca Zavin, and
I work on the Android Systems Team. We are
responsible for the Linux kernel and some
of the other low-level software.
>>Dan Bornstein: I am Dan Bornstein. I am
the tech lead for the Dalvik virtual machine
and core libraries, the layer above what Rebecca
works on.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: I am Ficus Kirkpatrick.
I work on Android Market.
>>Debajit Ghosh: I am Debajit Ghosh. I am
the tech lead manager for Music Beta by Google.
I previously worked on the sync framework,
Google sync integrations, and the cloud-to-device
messaging APIs that we released last year
here at Google I/O.
>>Dianne Hackborn: I am Dianne Hackborn. I
am the tech lead on the Android framework,
so that the activities, intents, and view
hierarchy and stuff like that.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Hi, I am Xavier Ducrohet.
I am the lead for SDK on developer tools.
>>Andy Stadler: Hi, I am Andy Stadler. I have
been working on Android enterprise apps for
quite a while now, but for the last few weeks
I have been having a really good time building
apps for the Android@home initiative.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Hi, I am Jeff Hamilton, and
I worked on a bunch of different things. Most
recently I am working on the Android NFC stack.
>>Dan Morrill: I am Dan Morrill. I do open
source and compatibility these days.
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks everyone.
Just so you know, we will be transitioning
the last ten minutes of this talk for the
iRobot folks to talk about their robots, because
we thought that would be fun, so just you
should know that. So you should expect them
the last ten minutes of this talk.
So let's go ahead and get started with the
interrogation.
Again, please go to the mics if you want to
talk.
When will developers from more countries be
able to open Android merchant accounts to
sell their apps on the Android Market? What's
the schedule on that?
I am trying to put some personality into this.
Any info would be appreciated. There are many
developers waiting for this.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: We hear your concerns.
We are actively working on launching market
in more regions, more countries, and there's
actually some stuff coming up pretty soon
about this so I can't say anything about schedule
right now, but very soon.
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks, Ficus.
First mic, first person.
>> Hi. My question is it's actually about
the new music beta. I don't know if this is
premature to ask, but as a software developer
who has a music app out in the Android marketplace,
I'm wondering are developers going to have
access to that as we do now with the media
libraries, or is that something that's going
to be controlled by Google?
>>Debajit Ghosh: Should I repeat the question?
>>Chris DiBona: No. They heard it.
>>Debajit Ghosh: As to developer APIs for
Music Beta by Google, we don't have any open
APIs at this time.
>> You realize that's going to sort of destroy
anybody who is doing a music app.
>>Debajit Ghosh: Sorry; I am talking about
the cloud portion specifically.
>> That's what I am talking about as well.
Until now, there has been no easy way of getting
the music on the phone, and now there is,
and you are saying the libraries you have
developed to do that, we won't have access.
to?
>>Debajit Ghosh: No, the APIs that currently
exist will be supported. So like, for example,
the media provider and so on will continue
to provide information as it currently does
about music that is installed or present on
the SD card and so on.
I don't know, and maybe you are not the right
person to know either what the behavior on
the device S.
Do you know anything about this? So what will
we do -- obviously if you are streaming music,
it may or may not appear in the provider.
>> The music libraries as they stand, if somebody
has music on the phone they can play them
in any developers' music player.
>>Dan Morrill: Right.
>> So it would seem to me it would make sense
we should be able to do the same thing with
the cloud if that's there, or if we are not
allowed to do that, then we are done.
>>Dan Morrill: I don't think we have anybody,
like, representing the actual music library.
I don't know what the behavior on the device
is, but the media provider, API and all that
that exists on device must continue to function
in some way.
So apps won't be completely broken but I don't
have an answer right now for what they will
see.
>> What I am asking is will we have access
to the cloud-based music service? Is that
a yes or no?
>>Chris DiBona: I don't think he knows yet.
>> They don't know. Okay.
Because as I say, it either seems like a major
opportunity or kind of the time to call it
quits.
>>Chris DiBona: I have to admit, I don't see
the latter as being as probable, I guess.
I think that having streaming music is really
neat and important and stuff, but I don't
think it means the end to all on-device MP3
files and all on-device music players.
Maybe I am not as pessimistic as you are,
or as optimistic as you are about our chances,
but, I mean -- I don't mean that in a mean
way. I just don't think it's the end of music
just because we start doing streaming.
>> No, I don't think it's the end of music,
but as I say, I see this as either a great
thing or something, as I say, that makes me
not so motivated to continue on.
>>Dan Morrill: Let me clarify by being a bit
more specific. We have this media provider
that says this is the music that's on the
device. Basically what you are asking is will
that -- or essentially one thing that it could
do is say it could show tracks that are in
the cloud, even though they are not present
on the device, or it could only show tracks
that physically present on the device. All
I am saying is I don't know what the behavior
of the app is.
>> Beyond that. What I want to know is will
I be able to play music in my app off the
Google music cloud?
>>Dan Morrill: Right. And right now, we don't
know the answer to that. My suggestion would
be to ask that in the Android developers group,
and we can rustle up the right person there
to get the answer to the question.
>>Chris DiBona: Let's go to the second mic
back, black-shirt dude.
>> Thanks.
My question was today you announced more of
a unification between the Google TV and Android
tablets and phones. I'm wondering if you can
talk about maybe in the future, any kind of
merging with the Chrome code base. What's
going to happen to Chrome, eventually, and
Android?
>>Chris DiBona: I would bring that up to the
Chrome Fireside Chat.
[ Laughter ]
>> It seems like Android is eventually going
to take over in that sense.
>>Chris DiBona: Android and Chrome share a
fair amount of code through the Web kit stuff
and through some of the browser stuff. So
that might continue, but we have nothing really
to say at this time other than that.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Ask the Chrome team.
>>Chris DiBona: So Anthony Prasaud from Irvine,
California says: Are there any plans to have
layout tool, aka interface builder, for building
Android apps?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes. We already have one,
kind of. I mean, it's not finished, I agree,
but we already have one and we are heavily
working on it.
I actually have a session tomorrow afternoon
where I will show a lot of the new feature
in there so I encourage you to attend that
talk.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris DiBona: They really like that answer.
>>Andy Stadler: I can just say I have been
using it for this @Home stuff, and it was
a nice change from tweaking XML.
>>Chris DiBona: Isn't everything, though?
Okay.
Red-shirt fellow in the front mic.
>> Hi. My question is on data SMS. Currently,
if you send a SMS in (inaudible) of the application,
we can do that but it's not directly to a
port. Anybody can take the message and use
it on their app. So my question is what's
the direction? Are we going to, in future
android releases, support data SMS or are
we going to go away from data SMS and use
(inaudible) full-fledged?
>>Chris DiBona: Unfortunately, we don't have
a telephony person up here, so we are kind
of screwing you.
>>Dave Sparks: I remember that technology.
>>Chris DiBona: We have no answer for you.
We're bad people.
Back mic, gray shirt.
>> I have two questions but I will keep them
brief and ask them both up front. They are
bought about Android Market.
I recently saw statistics about your apps
and how they are performing but missing is
downloads you get per day, downloads you get
historically. So I have been keeping a spreadsheet
by hand every day of the number of downloads.
I still have to do that even though all the
stuff you guys have added. It's pretty important
information. So I am wondering when you will
give people the ability to look at their download
trends and download spreadsheets or just anything
better than a single static number.
The other thing is Tim Bray has been good
about getting you guys to blog more, which
is awesome, but the Android support forums
are filled with many, many threads where there
has been no official answer. There's a lot
of simmering resentment on these threads,
irrational or not. Do you guys have any plans
on increasing how well you support that forum?
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: I can speak to the stat
stuff. It seems like I have been blogging
more, but not enough. You want more, I understand.
Yeah, I think that's a good idea. Again, I
don't have a schedule to announce but I agree
with you, it seems like important information,
and I think as we continue to push a lot of
the developer features forward, like we did
with the launch of all the really cool new
stat stuff, that will be coming.
As far as resentment, I think that's something
we want to see trending downward in general,
but I think that's really more of a developer
relations question.
>>Dan Morrill: I do see Tim over there.
>>Chris DiBona: No, it's okay. You can answer
for him.
>>Dan Morrill: No, I think we need to hear
from Tim.
He should walk faster.
>> Tim: So fortunately, these guys are pretty
easy to convince to blog. So we will keep
cracking the whip on that and we will try
-- we have an internal target to try and get
something done of substantial technical import
at least once a week so we will go on doing
that. But at the end of the day, keep in mind,
look at the size of this room. We are totally
outnumbered. And we really need to be in the
business of teaching the teachers.
>>Chris DiBona: You guys should also take
this opportunity to say you are hiring.
>>Dan Morrill: This thing is talking to me.
>>Chris DiBona: The robot is talking to you?
>>Dan Morrill: Yes. The robot is saying excuse
me.
>>Chris DiBona: Are you sure?
>>Dan Morrill: Oh, I am quite positive.
>>Chris DiBona: It is saying excuse me? It
wants attention?
>>Jeff Hamilton: I am confirm that.
>> Don't bad touch the robot.
>>Chris DiBona: From the market -- here is
a great one. I really like this question.
From Barrajos (phonetic), from a country that
is actually his company name. What about a
better emulator? When will it be available?
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes, so we are very aware
the emulator is difficult to use these days.
We are working on it. We don't have a whole
lot to announce because it's in the ready,
but I have a demo at my talk tomorrow, and
it's in that room, so I encourage you to talk.
>>Chris DiBona: What time is your talk?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Three-something. I'm not
sure, in this room.
>>Chris DiBona: In this room.
>>Dave Sparks: You will be here; right?
>>Chris DiBona: I think I have to go back
to the second microphone, to the person with
the print shirt.
>> Yeah, I am looking for a way to gain access
to an event when a file is added, changed
--
>>Chris DiBona: Like e pole interface, that
kind of thing?
>> Yeah, either in the framework or down in
the core somewhere. Is that available?
>> Excuse me.
>>Chris DiBona: That was the robot.
>> If the robot knows, that's fine.
[ Applause ]
>>Dianne Hackborn: There's a class called
file observer that lets you monitor the file
system.
>> Perfect. Is that going to be unprotected
files, I assume? Nothing that's sandboxed?
>>Dianne Hackborn: Only your own files.
>> Your own files. How about stuff on the
SD card? Pictures, music that, kind of thing?
>>Dianne Hackborn: It should work on the SD
card although I have not tested that, but
I believe it does.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Kapow!
>>Chris DiBona: There you go. we answered
one. That's great.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Hat guy. Love your hat. It's
an Android hat, Android being what you are
here for.
>> We are using the compatibility layer for
Honeycomb pretty extensively and there are
a couple of bugs in there that are significant
to what we're doing. Do you guys have a release
schedule for that or planning any updates
to the compatibility there?
>>Dianne Hackborn: This is the fragment compatibility
library?
>> Yeah.
>>Dianne Hackborn: MR1 will have an update
to it that I think addresses, like, animation
and some other issues people had.
>> Is there a release date?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Is it ready?
>> Today.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: No, I didn't push anything
so if the package is ready, I just push it
after I/O, I guess.
>>Rebecca Zavin: That's the release date for
the update that should start going out to
Verizon customers on Xooms today.
>>Dan Morrill: I have a quick public service
announcement, just because I feel it's important
that the world know this. The green Android
as depicted in the hats I seen in the room
here, he has no official name but we call
him the bug Droid.
So I have seen in the press people calling
him Andy and things like that, but I wanted
to make sure you guys know that we call him
the bug Droid.
>>Chris DiBona: You sound almost offended.
All right.
Are we going to see carrier billing for users
in countries outside the United States? And
in general, there are a number of when will
we get music, books and movies launched in
countries other than the U.S. So two international
questions for you.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: We already have carrier
billing outside the U.S. It's been launched
at least in Japan.
>>Chris DiBona: Japan is not in the United
States.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Last I heard. And to
the other question about launching in more
countries, same thing. We are always looking
to integrate with more carriers, bring people
more ways to buy apps.
As far as the books and movies question, I
think a lot of that is dependent on licensing
deals. Again, no schedule.
>>Chris DiBona: I think the back -- front
-- back microphone's turn. You, dark shirt.
>> Hi, Chris, I am one of your GSOC mentors.
>>Chris DiBona: Awesome.
>>Can I ask the hard question or the easy
one?
>>Chris DiBona: It's up to you, but you have
to ask one now.
>> Okay, okay. The hard one, then.
So when do you think Google will release a
source version of Android that, when built,
provides complete hardware support in every
single feature that's in the closed packages
that the carriers provide? In other words,
when will we have a complete open source Android?
Alternatively, can we call it Android slash
Linux? Sorry, I saw RMS a couple weeks ago
and it's been on my mind. But yeah.
>>Dan Morrill: So yeah. The Nexus S has -- we
reached agreements with the various chipset
vendors in the Nexus S to include redistributable,
under noncommercial terms, at least, versions
of the binary drivers for most of the components,
and we are working with chipset vendors on
the remaining components. What this basically
means is check out of the AOSP source code
plus files that you download from our Web
site plus make equals bootable fully functional
device.
>> Right. Except there's no source code, so
I couldn't take it and put it into, say, Poulsbo
or any other SGX graphics --
>>Dan Morrill: You will have to talk to the
chipset vendors about that. Realistically
--
>> They said no.
>>Dan Morrill: Well, it's their decision,
for the most part.
There's all kinds of IP restrictions on this
that they are bound by. That's not a landscape
that we really understand or really have that
much insight into.
So, for example, like the radio image that
runs on the secondary processor in most of
these phones, that's completely opaque to
us for the most part.
So it's not -- we are sort of a software vendor
to chips and software that runs on these chips
that we don't really have the insight into.
So what we can do is produce the drivers and
make sure that those are available under useful
terms, at least for the devices that we ship
ourselves, but unfortunately, it's really
in the hands of the chipset vendors and the
OEMs to really kind of complete the loop.
>> That's deeply unfortunate.
Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: Well, it's less deeply unfortunate
now than it was when we launched the G1. Each
iterative step, when we do the full Android
open source release, we end up having more
and more of those components in place. So
this isn't the kind of war you win. It's a
constant, ongoing effort to keep more and
more things open.
So we just work hard at that. And it's better
now than it was two years ago. It's better
now than it was a year ago, and it will be
better in a year from now than it is now.
So that's actually something I am kind of
proud of with the team.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks.
White shirt microphone. One of the major things
that is an issue with Android, next to battery
life sometimes, is fragmentation. So there's
a lot of choice. You have over 300 devices,
which is a good thing for the consumer, but
is sometimes a nightmare for developers. And
I think mostly for game developers. So there
are a lot of things being done from within
the Android team but are there additional
things that are being launched, additional
initiatives to help produce those fragmentation,
help developers? This question gets asked
every year, and the answer is usually the
same. We do do what we can, and we are continually
improving the CTS test. One thing which actually
is really useful is that the CTS -- sorry,
which is the compatibility test suite, is
developed in the open. Like right now, it's
actually not because there's Honeycomb tests
that are useless without Honeycomb source,
obviously. But, like, for example, if you
encounter a bug in Gingerbread, you being
you as a developer, encounter a bug in Gingerbread,
you can submit a test to us to cover that
case, which will fix it for future devices
and so on.
So really part of it is do check out the CTS,
and if there is something you can contribute,
it will help a lot there.
At the same time, there are other problems.
You mentioned game developers in particular,
and that's certainly true. I don't know how
much Dave can comment on where we are with
some of the stuff that we're planning on -- for
some of the openGL related topics and things
like that. That's really his and I don't know
a great deal about that. But in general, what
we aim to do is improve these things over
the next few releases and then, of course,
at the same time, we're also working, as we
announced this morning, more aggressively
with the OEMs and carriers to make sure updates
get out there more regularly and so on. Dave,
did you want to talk about --
>>Dave Sparks: We are work being with the
chipset vendors on compatible issues. GPU,
that's an area we are painfully aware of.
The problem -- This is no different than a
desktop system; right? They all have their
own texture, formats. And typically they are
protected by patents.
So it's not like we have a lot we can do in
that area, but we are certainly working on
it.
We're working within Khronos to help standardize
some things, like a good example of something
we have done recently is the texture streaming
stuff in Honeycomb, which allows you to take
video or camera frames and move them directly
into the GPU and render those within a 3D
scene graph.
So we're working at that level with the chipset
vendors to try to get more common functionality
across all the devices by creating extensions
that are specific to Android, like this texture
streaming stuff.
So it's a difficult situation. I think it's
going to get better, especially over the next
year. And GPUs are an area where things are
advancing really quickly. You know, we are
seeing performance jumps, we are seeing all
kinds of new features in the GPUs, and those
will, for the next probably three or four
years, you are going to see doubling in performance.
So I think that's an area that's very promising.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Sticky Notes.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: I wanted to add on the
market side, we're going to be adding a lot
of stuff to address the issues particularly
games producers have. It's a tough problem,
and we're going to try to help you deal with
it. I'd really encourage anyone who -- this
is a topic near and dear to your heart, to
attend Eric Chu's talk tomorrow morning.
>>Chris DiBona: Sérgio in Lisbon says are
there plans to let the developers respond
to feedback and reviews from their users,
which I think is pretty important.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris DiBona: That guy thinks it's really
important, too.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Yes.
>>> (off mike).
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Excuse me? Time frame.
Not clear. We're working on it.
>>Chris DiBona: Similarly, will the marketplace
have plans to support the use of promo codes
for free downloads for marketing purposes?
That's kind of a specific ask, but, you know.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: That, as far as I know,
we do not have plans for right now.
But I wouldn't rule it out. But I am not personally
working on it right now.
>>Chris DiBona: Okay.
The blue shirt on the second microphone.
>>> Yeah, any plans to upgrade the support
for larger apps? I know 50 megs is pretty
much the limit right now. With tablet apps,
or more tablets out there, more ability to
support some really large apps that particularly
have a lot of audio or video in them?
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Absolutely, yes.
Again, you should come to Eric Chu's talk
tomorrow morning. We are going to have some
stuff to show.
>>> Three quick questions.
When will the CTUM graduate from Google Labs.
When will the porting guide be back up and
updated. And.
>>> Any hope of seeing Honeycomb source if
we wanted to support legacy tablets or do
we have to wait for Ice Cream Sandwich?
>>Chris DiBona: Do you want to start with
the Honeycomb source question? That's asked
in the thing, too.
>>Dan Morrill: So I guess you asked about
the porting guide.
That went away because it was basically obsolete
and it was essentially actively misleading.
So we're, like, better to not have anything
than -- and let people look at the source
to figure out how the build system works than
to actively give them erroneous info.
So -- but at the same time, we know there
is some good info there that needs to come
back. We're working on it. What we're doing
right now is gathering information that in
fact some of the people on this lineup that
you see here owe me, you know, kind of technical
information that I need to relaunch a sort
of replacement for this section.
So we've been really busy preparing for I/O.
I know it's a bit inconvenient. And we'll
get some content back up there when it's actually
useful and correct and accurate and up-to-date.
And I think I missed. What was the Honeycomb
source question?
>>> Is the source code ever going to be really
open source?
>>Dan Morrill: That's an interesting question.
And to answer it, I need to answer it in the
form of an explanation of GIT. So for those
who are not terribly familiar with GIT, it's
a system that tracks individual bits and reassembles
them as you instruct it to. And this is an
terrifying and as awesome as it sounds.
What this means is you can think of Honeycomb
as this sort of gigantic collection of a bunch
of little patches stored in GIT. If you asked
the question, will we ever release this in
the Honeycomb source, well, we can't not and
yet still release the Ice Cream Sandwich,
because these patches will still all be there
in the history of, you know, whatever source
we push that is Ice Cream Sandwich.
So, you know, in other words, Honeycomb is
sort of a set of patches. Ice Cream Sandwich
is a larger set of patches that also includes
all of the Honeycomb patches.
So the source will inevitably get out there
in one form or another. The question is will
we essentially tag it in such a way as to
let somebody reconstruct a, you know, like
a Honeycomb build from that source. That's
what we don't know right now.
It depends on how things shake out in the
fourth quarter when we get ready to look at
Ice Cream Sandwich releases.
>>> So before fourth quarter, we won't see
it? Or we won't see anything that will allow
us to build, essentially, a Honeycomb image
for a legacy tablet, for example?
>>Dan Morrill: As far as I know right now,
that's correct.
>>David Sparks: We announced specifically
we're not releasing Honeycomb source.
>>> The final question was the C2DM, when
will it graduate? It was supposed to graduate
from Google Labs by December of last year.
It still, as far as I know, requires official
approval.
>>Chris DiBona: Which one are you talking
about?
>>> C2DM, the cloud to device messaging.
>>Debajit Ghosh: It's doing really well. There's
a tremendously amount of usage for it. I don't
recall ever setting a date for when it will
graduate from Google Labs.
It's -- you know, it's on our priority list.
But I have nothing to announce at this time.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: The fellow on the second microphone.
>>> Honeycomb provides support for storage
encryption. What are the encryption algorithms
used and what is the encryption file system
used in -- for storage encryption in Honeycomb?
>>Rebecca Schultz Zavin: You mean the file
system data partition encryption? It's sitting
on top of dm-crypt, which is something that's
supported in the kernel. And I think it's
-- I don't want to mislead you, but I think
it's AES128. I'm pretty sure.
>>> Okay.
>>Chris DiBona: What are your plans for the
NFC APIs? In this case, I'd say just watch
the NFC session, which is later today; right?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Can you repeat the question?
>>Chris DiBona: Just what are the plans for
the NFC APIs.
>>Jeff Hamilton: For NFC APIs?
>>Chris DiBona: Yes.
>>Jeff Hamilton: In Android 2.3.3, we released
much more support for NFC, quite a variety
of APIs that allow full reader/writer support
so you can interact with all sorts of legacy
NFC devices. That came up pretty recently.
2.3.4 doesn't have any additional support
for new APIs. But 2.3.3 had a bunch of new
stuff there.
We're giving a talk right after this one in
this room going into more detail on NFC. So
I suggest listening to that.
>>Chris DiBona: Stick around for that if you
want that.
>>> Two questions. First question about Chrome.
What are the challenges to enable full Chrome
browser used on Android.
>>Chris DiBona: There's no Chrome browser
on Android, so there's a lot of challenges,
I would imagine. I would ask the Chrome guys
during their fireside.
What's your second question?
>>> Second question is, is there a plan to
enable, like, Android virtual machine in a
different environment. For instance, within
Chrome, Android virtual machine.
>>Chris DiBona: I would ask the Chrome guys.
I don't know what their plans are around that.
>>Dan Bornstein: There's nothing particularly
technical stopping that from happening. That's
nothing that anybody up here -- it's just
programming, you know.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah, blue shirt in the back.
>>> I would love to be able to learn from
the apps you build in large-scale apps, like
the Google Apps, GMail, Books. Is there any
plans on making that available for developers
to learn from?
>>Chris DiBona: Dan?
>>Dan Morrill: So you mean like, what, like
a case studies or like a technical sort of
--
>>> The source code.
>>Dan Morrill: Oh, the source code.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Morrill: Oh.
>>Chris DiBona: Gosh, how they do that.
>>Dan Morrill: Yeah, that's -- I'm going to
say no.
It's -- it's come up before. I mean, you know,
we periodically revisit it. But, you know,
essentially, it's -- the reality is that even
aside from the fact that there is, you know,
intellectual property that's extremely important
to Google in there, the -- the reality is
that a lot of the, you know, partners are,
you know, motivated to work with us and make
sure that their devices are compatible and
so on, you know, because we, you know, license
the stuff to them. And so if we make it too
freely available, you know, then that sort
of reduces the incentive of, you know, a lot
of the members of the ecosystem to, you know,
continue to make compatible devices and work
for user and developer experience and so on.
So it's a tricky situation for us.
We do think about that periodically. But right
now, that's not something that we're able
to do.
>>> Would in-depth case studies be a possibility?
>>Dan Morrill: That's an interesting question,
actually. We do have the mobile blog, and
they've talked about, like, we've done blog
posts about things like, you know -- like
-- I think they did a blog post about how
they did the GMail -- or the mobile Web version
of GMail. We can certainly look at that.
>>Chris DiBona: We should make Tim Bray do
that. Because he's not up here.
>>Dan Morrill: That would be pretty interesting.
I'd read it.
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah. You, sir.
>>> I was pretty excited when app inventor
came out. I realize it's not going to give
us rich, deep UI and things that we can do
in native development more the traditional
way. But I think it has a lot of potential
to produce a lot of really simple apps for
people who are not as technically savvy.
Is there any plans to bring that out of sort
of the experimentation mode it's in now to
make it possible to bring an app from App
Inventor to the market?
>>Dan Morrill: I don't think -- that's a different
team at Google, actually, that did that. I
don't think -- we don't have anybody here,
and I don't think we really know the answer
to that.
>>Chris DiBona: Are they even in the sandbox?
That's the question.
I think they're in the sandbox.
>>> Okay.
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah. So I would find Sharon
or Mark and go talk to them over there.
>>> Thanks.
>>Chris DiBona: Shirt in the second mike.
>>> Okay. How does renderscript relate to
OpenCL? Is it seen as an replacement or can
we expect OpenCL in the future rendering versions?
>>David Sparks: We're -- we see it as a -- sort
of equivalent to OpenCL that is tailored for
the Android environment.
Android has this really rich API in Java,
and we have no intention to duplicate that
API for every other language out there. So
if you want to get access to all the rich
APIs in Java, you need to have a Java application
of some sort.
Renderscript basically gives you dynamic findings
from Java to your native code. So that's why
we think it's viable. Basically, your program
needs something that looks a lot like C99,
so it's easy to port code over. We have a
few little extensions we've thrown in to give
you the multithreading and some additional
extensions, extrinsics that will come along
later on to take advantage of GPU architecture
and CPU architectures in the future that will
basically be done in the (inaudible) device.
So if a new device comes out with new features,
your application will automatically get whatever
acceleration there is.
So it's basically, we think, a better way
of getting at native performance from a, you
know, interpret -- effectively, interpreted
language, but not really.
So it -- there's no plans to do OpenCL. I
think you'll probably see other companies
that are interested in doing that. But we
have no plans to support it.
>>> Okay.
>>> Okay. Android's great on high-end devices
with flat-rate data contracts. But as you
move further down the scale or across the
world, you're more likely to be on a metered
contract. And I've seen requests from many
users asking for more control over which applications
can access the Internet and when. Is this
something you guys are likely to support or
is this against your ideology?
>>David Sparks: Do you want to take that?
>>Dianne Hackborn: Yeah, we're looking into
this.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Very closely.
Does Ice Cream Sandwich mean all Android devices
become Google TV devices for free when using
the HDMI output? Are any of these Google TV
type output available in Honeycomb 3.1 before
Ice Cream Sandwich is released? Does Ice Cream
Sandwich mean all Android devices become Google
TV devices for free when using HDMI output?
I know the answer to that, and that's no.
Because there's all this other stuff that
goes into a Google TV that isn't in a phone.
Are any of these -- Basically, it's asking
for a UI that will scale to a larger screen
via the HDMI output on a tablet. So I don't
know if you have any plans for that.
>>Dianne Hackborn: Yes, we definitely are
thinking about what happens when you plug
your phone into HDMI output and you have a
bigger screen on it. We have a lot of stuff
in the platform today to, you know, have -- activities
restart when these kind of conversion changes
happen.
We're going a little slow on this because
it has a big impact on developers. So, like,
having -- your applications now have to deal
with the screen size suddenly changing significantly
on you. We want to make sure you have all
the tools for this you need in there.
But, you know, we -- there's already devices
out there shipping that have this kind of
-- that do this kind of thing. And it's definitely
on our minds about how to do this really seamlessly
in Android.
>>Chris DiBona: I think, actually, the second
mike.
>>> Are there any improvements coming to the
developer dashboard that you can share with
us? For example, it would be really useful
to be able to filter by version number.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Filter by version number
of what?
>>> Filter crash reports by version.
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: I see. As I spoke about
earlier, you know, we did a push recently
with improved stats reporting on the developer
site. And more is coming. So that one is one
that I -- I personally have thought would
be really useful. I'd also like to be able
to filter by device type so you guys can see,
like, if somebody with an EVO is crashing,
you know, you can track that down.
>>> Great. Thanks.
>>> So I'm just curious if there have been
any improvements in hardware acceleration
in Android 3.1 or perhaps future releases,
such as Ice Cream Sandwich, because it seems
like there's a lot of lag across the board
with the tablet operating system right now.
>>David Sparks: You're developing on a tablet
now and you're seeing lag?
>>> Yes.
>>David Sparks: Have you done profiling to
find out where it is?
>>> Just in the whole operating system itself,
whether -- even if you're scrolling in the
GMail app by Google, it's just sort of --
>>David Sparks: Okay, just sort of in general
performance?
We're constantly looking at performance.
We -- certainly performance is one of the
things we're going to look at in Ice Cream
Sandwich in terms of our improvements across
the board.
Generally, when we dig down into performance
issues, it's the application that's at fault
rather than the -- the system itself, most
of the time, not always.
We spend a lot of time -- Honeycomb has a
lot of improvements across the board in terms
of acceleration. We're doing GPU compositing.
We're -- if you have your application with
the proper manifest flag, you can take advantage
of GPU acceleration. Fonts are cached in the
GPU. We're doing -- compositing the GPU. Where
we can take advantage of it, we take advantage
of overlay composition.
So it really -- you know, if the device is
-- the device manufacturer has done a good
job on their abstraction layers, then it can
run at 60 frames a second rock solid. When
we start looking at problems where it's not
hitting that, it's usually something in the
app itself, not always, but usually.
>>> I'm just noticing that all across the
board with tablets, it seems like an issue,
whereas with newer Android phones, even dual-core
ones, it doesn't seem to be a problem.
>>David Sparks: Without specifics, I -- you
know, it's -- the system performance thing
is a pretty complex problem. So it may be
-- and I'm not sure what devices you're talking
about. But it may be something related to
that specific device.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>> I'm interested in frame buffer access
for screen shots and for remote control applications.
And currently, the story for this is fragmented.
Some devices simply allow you to do that.
In other cases, you can use some rather clunky
methods to accomplish it.
I'm wondering if this will become part of
the core platform that's supported on all
devices. And if not, why not? I understand
there are some security implications to that.
But that's what the permission system is for.
So I'd like to find out more about what the
plans are for that.
>>Dianne Hackborn: Well, I hope none of the
devices actually let you do this. Because
that is a security issue.
We are -- being able to -- letting the user
take screen shots is definitely something
we know people have wanted for a long time.
I guess it's worth mentioning the thumbnails
now in the Honeycomb UI, those are actually
done by taking a screen shot of the screen
when the application -- when you leave the
application. So we have some infrastructure
in there to do that now. And we should be
exposing something for that fairly soon.
For application access, we don't have any
immediate plans for that.
>>Chris DiBona: From the Internet, there's
a question here, it's sort of interestingly
formed, so I'll just try to distill it.
There are questions about audio latency being
a problem for Android. Are you seeing this,
Dave?
>>David Sparks: Latency, really?
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah, latency. Like, you know,
sending --
>>David Sparks: Never heard of it.
No, we know latency --
>>Chris DiBona: And it says "compared to the
iPhone." And it uses a star instead of the
whole name of the iPhone. It's okay to type
"iPhone" into Google.
>>David Sparks: That's something a spell checker
changes --
>>Chris DiBona: Maybe.
>>David Sparks: Latency is a big problem.
We're working at -- we hope to be able to
do something about it with ICS. As we investigate
it, it's actually a pretty complex problem.
There are a number of different places where
latency gets introduced. Most of the latency
is introduced below the -- below Android.
Basically, it's happening in the drivers or
on the chipsets or somewhere in there. And
some of these are really obscene amounts,
hundreds of milliseconds of latency in the
audio path.
So it's something we're going to push on.
We started -- I think we introduced something
in CDD Gingerbread, I want to say, which was
a should, you know, hit certain latencies.
There are some interesting problems we need
to solve in the scheduler, so I'll be talking
to Rebecca shortly about this. Because the
(inaudible) scheduler makes it really difficult
to make sure that these low-latency audio
threads get scheduled when we need them to
be scheduled every single time. That's probably
the biggest issue we're running into right
now.
But it's a problem we have to deal with and
hopefully the next release will get it. Obviously
it's not going to solve the problems for legacy
devices, but it's going to get better.
>> I have a serious question for the market
guy, and then I have a lighter question.
Is it at all possible that we might be able
to see Android slash Google checkout gift
cards to send virtual gifts this holiday season
coming up and not miss that boat all together
in the Android Market?
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: It's certainly possible.
>> Is it on the agenda, maybe?
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: It's something we're
looking at, for sure.
>> And then the lighter question is, bug Droid?
Really?
>> Yes, yes!
>>Chris DiBona: It was going to be Phillip,
but it didn't work.
The second microphone, please.
>> Sure. Any plans to support unicode characters
in the future?
>>Dan Bornstein: We already support unicode
in general. Do you have something --
>> Characters like Hindi or Tamil or like
that.
>>Dan Bornstein: There are a couple of possible
questions. One might be about fonts, one might
be input methods.
>> I have used fonts but they don't appear
that good. So I want to see whether some basic
support is there. iPhone 4 already supports
it, Windows supports it. I am just wondering,
when does Android does it?
>>Dan Bornstein: So I don't know when -- We
are constantly revving our fonts, adding new
characters. Obviously, I don't know about,
like, what schedule we have for any new sets
of characters offhand. I know that we are
continually adding new sets. So my guess is
eventually, we will cover your territory,
but we don't have a schedule for that.
>>Dave Sparks: There is another issue which
is just the size. We can't include every single
font out there. So manufacturers have a choice
of fonts they put into a device. It's going
to be dictated by what geography is for that
device. So you are not going to see a device
that have universal support for every single
language out. There so it's definitely going
to be regional.
>>Dianne Hackborn: And to that, there is work
going on right now for complex character shaping
and bi-di supports. I can't give you a date
for that, but that is something that is being
worked on that.
>>Dan Morrill: There are actually threads
on that on the android-contrib mailing list,
so if you want to find out what the details
are, the guys working on that are actually
on that list, and there's a thread that might
be interesting and provide you some specific
info there, too.
>> Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: The fellow at the first microphone.
>> What, if anything, are you doing in terms
of real-time support in Android? Or support
for embedded systems beyond the platforms
you support now.
>>Chris DiBona: For rocket control, that kind
of thing?
>> Whatever.
>>Chris DiBona: I guess the iRobot guys are
coming up. They can answer that.
>>Rebecca Zavin: I can try. It depends on
what you mean by real time and what kind of
systems you are envisioning.
In terms of other embedded systems, you know,
we certainly have, in the past, worked directly
on a number of different chipsets and there
are others supported by the chipset vendors
and by the various OEMs.
>> And real-time support?
>>Rebecca Zavin: I have to get a sense of
exactly what you are looking for. From a platform
perspective? I wouldn't think that would necessarily
be something we would do. But from a -- if
you wanted to put Android on top of whatever
operating system, low-level kernel operating
system with support, that's within the domain
of any developer or chipset vendor.
>> Okay.
>>Chris DiBona: Okay. So if your question
is super short, we can take it; otherwise,
we will wrap up. I will remind everyone we
have office hours throughout the days, so
please find us there.
Is it short? Make it short. The other people
we won't be able to get to because we are
going to go on to the next guys.
>> When a user installs an app, it seems like
the market prompts them about the reason why
they uninstalled it. As a developer, can we
get that data?
>>Chris DiBona: Ficus?
>>Ficus Kirkpatrick: Not currently.
>> Are there any plans --
>>Chris DiBona: Not currently.
>> -- for that?
>>Chris DiBona: Sorry.
Thank you, guys. You can get off the stage
now.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris DiBona: I would like to welcome a
question from the moderator which is I have
a question for the robot. When will you be
available for purchase?
.
>>Colin Angle: Thank you.
The answer to the question is the robot, we
are going to be talking about today, is going
to be available as a developer version this
year. So that if you are interested in working
with us, come up to our booth, give us your
name and we will be developing these guys
and building more of them throughout the year,
and so that we already have several of these
robots here being worked on by the Google
team. And more of them will come into existence
as the year plays out.
So, hello. My name is Colin Angle. I am the
co-founder, CEO and chairman of iRobot, but
I lay that all aside in the spirit of Chris's
introduction at the beginning of this Fireside
Chat.
I am an engineer. I am a double E with minor
in computer science, and he said that when
engineers talk to engineers, interesting things
happen, and hopefully we can be true to that
charge, because there's a big question out
there, where are the robots?
And I will tell you that, well, let's just
-- I need a show of hands. When I was growing
up, I always assumed that there would be more
robots in the world than exist today. How
many people in the audience are satisfied
with the current state of robotics?
All right. We have one hands up in the entire
audience.
Now, there's a reason for that, and the reason
is that we have been seduced by the coolness
of robots, by the vision and the dream of
robots, and forgotten the fact that industries
are created when the right business conditions
allow for the robots and businesses to be
created. For example, there is not going to
be a robot industry until more companies create
robots that deliver more value than they cost
to produce. Academia has been overperforming
in the world of robots. We have a tremendous
amount of technology being developed for robots,
but we don't have enough robotic products.
And so I am here to make an appeal to all
of you to help solve the challenge of the
lack of robots in the world.
So there's three ways that this robotic business
becomes real. The first is to find problems
so critical, so dramatic that only a robot
can solve it, and, thus it, doesn't matter
how much the robot costs. Okay. Here are some
examples. We have 4,000 robots that we created
over in Iraq and Afghanistan defusing bombs.
There's an incredibly valuable thing. The
robots -- what matters is you can throw these
things off two-story, three-story buildings,
they survive. They save soldiers' lives. You
can create a business around that.
We have robots at the Fukushima Daiichi nuclear
power plant right now, going into the power
plant helping to find out what's going on,
not a good thing for people to be doing.
So there are businesses that we can create
there.
A second thing is to find robot-friendly tasks
to do. Robots are really good at vacuuming
the floor, because the floor is flat, not
a lot of objects around. You can have a moderately
sophisticated navigation system and do very,
very well there, and you can build such robots
for hundreds of dollars instead of hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
So the Roomba, six million sold.
But the third one is an interesting one. The
third one is technology advancements enabling
robots to do more things, more like Rosie
from the Jetsons, the type of interactions
we all thought of.
That's where you all come in because the robot
industry can't be trusted to solve this problem.
We need the mobile computing industry to come
in and save our bacons to some extent through
the creation of stuff like this (indicating).
Why? Because these tablets, you can talk to
them. They have done more for voice recognition
than robotics has in decades.
Image understanding, voice and video over
IP. Very good and strong development tools
exist to make these tablets easy to interact
with.
So what we at the robot industry realized
was this is a fantastic head for a robot.
Okay? It does everything. You have got a camera
on this thing, you have got speakers, you
have got a microphone input. You can put eyes
and faces on this thing. This is a fantastic
head for a robot.
So what was missing is the body.
So here is a robot called AVA. We have got
these things running around and what does
this robot do? It navigates. It builds maps.
It carries tablets. It has big speakers on
it. It has batteries, power supplies, things
like that. So this robot, our guys, our engineers
have gone around and mapped this whole conference
room center. We have a screen so you can,
on your tablet, push a button and say go there,
and it will go and drive through the mobs,
make it to where it needs to go safely and
securely.
There's a processing system on here running
a low-level operating system, independent
of the tablet. So if the tablet crashes or
the tablet tells the robot to drive off this
cliff, the aware operating system here, which
has been architected not to crash, to do a
few things very, very well, will keep that
robot from doing something wrong.
So we have also developed a very sophisticated
API between aware and the tablets. So now
we have a platform which will make all much
you developers for applications for robots.
And what my company is doing is taking this,
making these robots commercially available
to developers this year, B2B applications
next year, and then beyond getting the price
point, so this is a practical thing to have
in households within a few years.
So our goal is to get the installed base up
so that you all can make money writing apps
for robots, so that we all can ultimately
achieve this vision of having robots impactfully
doing cool stuff for us in our lifetime.
So that's my pitch. And if you think about
what sort of apps are going on, you can think
about making information proactive. What happens
when you send an e-mail and the person doesn't
respond? The robot can get them.
[ Laughter ]
>>Colin Angle: Remote presence. What if I
could give this talk via robot, but not just
as a mobile video conferencing system; as
something I can tap on the screen, say go
follow that person. Or I can have cool software
which determines whether or not you are paying
attention and take your image being beamed
to me, make you red and say this person is
asleep. His name is Mark so you should pick
on him in the next comment you say. You can
have ways of projecting yourself via robot
that would be more impactful than being there
yourself.
And, of course, the last class of applications
is actually doing physical work, because robots
are physical. They are in our world, and so
that fetching, bringing things, going out
and doing the manual type of work which information
alone, obviously, can't deliver to us creates
a huge set of opportunities. So this is the
robot. We have a booth out there. We have
a all sorts of guys in black shirts who don't
say Google, they say iRobot on them. And we
love your support and interest in making these
dreams a reality.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]